[Music]
from the studio that just can't seem to
launch a franchise comes the reboot no
one wanted that ended up being really
fun and something I wouldn't mind seeing
more of is this is this what hope feels
like Jumanji welcome to the jungle you
loved the 1995 original now the reboot
is tossing out the setting the premise
the dead kids the Robin Williams and
pretty much everything except the name
but since I swore a blood oath to see
every movie the rock makes here we are
meet four teenagers who are all unique
and a Breakfast Club II kind of way
watch them learn self-confidence and
compassion just like The Breakfast Club
thanks to an action-packed day in
detention just like that other movie
bolita was called Power Rangers you must
be a bully of the tension grill as each
team is jumanji din to an avatar that
represents their character arc the nerd
who needs courage the jaw who needs
humility the weirdo who needs confidence
and the popular girl who needs to learn
how a penis works so it may be on the
nose but you'll laugh as all the actors
get to play against their usual toy
don't cry don't cry don't cry don't cry
don't cry I like can't even with this
place except for Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
always Kevin hordes
[Music]
enter Jumanji the board game that
literally rebooted itself for a new
generation that's sort of a riff on the
tropes of videogames I think he's an MPC
except when it drops the pretense to be
a normal adventure movie again I got
away I lost him in the jungle wait why
are the npcs talking to EJ yeah you know
I never mind but it still does a good
job poking fun at female heroes designed
by dudes why am I wearing this outfit in
a jungle scripted events doctor briefs
tone
Jumanji needs you Jumanji needs you
Jumanji need them you know and multiple
violent deaths that never seem to face
the characters you know if Mario was
real he'd never stop screaming after 35
years Jack Black finally returns to the
jungle with people by vanity crocodiles
while the rock just can't get enough in
the third chapter of his secret jungle
quadrilogy that's a pure celebration of
his rock appeal as Dwayne Johnson spends
an entire movie discovering the joys of
B Dwayne Johnson whether it's his arms
Jesus would you look at the size of that
thing
realizing he has no weaknesses none is
sex appeal
or the effect he has a large bearded man
damn that is a man right there you'll
totally buy into the height that's going
to make him the second least qualified
president someday so gear up earthquake
that surprised everyone at the box
office
pay proper respect to the original and
since Allen Paris's house I'm just
living in it and reminded every studio
that when most of your reboots
feature-length comedies and video game
movies are terrible will slob all over
you just for showing basic confidence
uh-oh
starring rocky player1 the cake is a lie
cake tenacious OMG ami respond American
Harry Styles Gus grimly too many cooks
and the Hornet defeated the jungle book
the game the movie the reboot the video
game good news keV we've got him on the
ropes
yay go us oh hey screen junkies want to
avoid more of your life click the Box on
the left to explore our new show smash
hit where he breakdown the career at
Will Smith or click the Box on the right
to see us play emoji games with John
Cena hopefully you can see him because
we could not it's a wild wild race feed
your hippos face Hungry Hungry Hippos
I'm actually a divorced woman I don't
say